Can you spot reduce while dieting to
lose only fat and nothing else if body
recomp is your goal let's talk about
best practices for fat loss not weight
loss while keeping that precious
metabolic muscle whether your goal is
body recomp or you're trying to improve
your health let's talk about the science
of fat loss over weight loss hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
before we get into today's video I'm
going to thank my colleagues at unlocked
Fitness Nutrition for assisting on the
research and evidence-based practical
advice I'm going to be linking to their
website below if you're looking for my
top trusted professionals when it comes
to Fitness and weight management support
I also want to remind everyone that I
will be sharing that loss related
information today which is at odds with
the official intuitive eating philosophy
personally and professionally I believe
in body autonomy and I get asked a lot
of questions about best practices for
safe fat loss so my goal as a science
Communicator is really to meet people
where they are with evidence-based
content and advice I don't want you
thinking that this is a suggestion from
me that people should all be trying to
lose fat or even wait I'm simply
responding to one of the most common
questions that I get asked with the best
quality science and a bit of my
signature sass okay hold up for a second
I want to tell you about today's sponsor
element so I'm really honored to be
working with element because this is a
product that I was using years ago when
I was on my breastfeeding Saga and it
really really helped me recover I ended
up getting back into it when I spent a
few months down south this year because
because I just have a really bad
tendency to get heat stroke or get super
dehydrated in the Sun so this really
saved me a lot of my colleagues who work
in Sports Nutrition also swear by
elements specifically because it has a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of a
thousand milligram sodium 200 milligrams
potassium and 60 milligrams magnesium
and it has no colors sugar or fillers
I've also found having my electrolytes
in the morning has also had a huge
impact on my sleep so even on days that
I'm not sweating a lot I'll usually
still have at least half a packet I love
all things spicy so the mango chili is
my current Obsession but they have nine
different flavors including their new
grapefruit which I also really love
right now element is offering my viewers
a free sample pack with any order so
that is eight single serving packets for
free with any element order and this is
a really great way to try all eight
flavors or to share element with a salty
friend so you can get yours at
drinkelement.com Abby sharp and this
deal is only available through my link
so you got to go to
d-r-i-n-k-l-mnt.com slash ABI Sharp
hmm
so good okay so before we get into some
of the best practices here in the
science it is worth pointing out that
when people die and lose weight about a
quarter of that weight on average is
water metabolic muscle mass and an
extreme weight loss cases are vital
organs like our heart and liver this is
actually one of the reasons for the high
mortality rates in folks with
restrictive EDS now some muscle loss may
be a bit inevitable but if someone does
insist on losing weight we ideally want
to skew as much as possible towards body
fat rather than that really important
metabolic muscle and this is not just
for body recomp Aesthetics which really
is not my key demographic here but for
the average individual just trying to
lose weight we know that it's the excess
fat that's associated with chronic
disease while a loss of that muscle mass
is associated with poor metabolic Health
heart health strength and risk of
Frailty later on in older age so this is
actually one of the main reasons why
people who've been dieting their whole
lives AKA weight cycling tend to end up
heavier over time each and every time a
person dies and loses weight they can
lose some percentage of that muscle and
then when they go off the diet and
they're eating normally again they gain
the weight back and typically that
weight regain is in fat so basically the
more weight cycling the less muscle mass
we maintain and the lower are resting
metabolism is so let's start by
answering some of the big questions that
I get asked all the time number one can
you spot reduce fat so for example I
personally have a little more fat in my
belly but I would love a little help in
the button boobs Department Becky look
at her butt so if I diet could I
potentially just lose the weight right
here well spot reduction or essentially
deliberately losing fat from a specific
region of the body is often rejected did
by the health and science community and
is often seen as a big fat myth the
problem is most studies that have
researched spot reduction haven't
actually included any trials who are a
significant amount of body fat loss was
observed so you can't just like shift
around where the existing fat is not
without surgery at least
I am a surgeon now generally speaking
when dieting the areas of the body that
have the most fat tend to be the areas
where fat is lost from first so in my
case theoretically I would lose more
weight in my belly than I would my boobs
that said while spot reduction is often
debated Spotlight pollosis is actually
clearly seen in the literature so this
is where individuals will break down
more fat tissue around the muscles that
they're exercising compared to other
areas in the body so for example a
cyclist would probably have super lean
legs but but maybe if they did have fat
in their body it might be in their belly
or somewhere else so in that sense like
spot reduction is actually in some ways
plausible but for spot reduction to
actually happen the following criteria
would likely be needed to be met number
one you need to be doing super super
high intensity exercise in the area that
you wanted to reduce two you would need
a super high energy expenditure during
or immediately after you exercise to
burn the fat that's being mobilized from
that area and three you would need to be
in a caloric deficit or state of energy
deficiency for weight and fat loss to
even occur it's a tall order the only
way you could spot reduce in less
extreme conditions without any sort of
like dieting or caloric restriction is
if you do a lot of aerobic exercise
which has been shown to reduce visceral
fat around the organs which is actually
the most dangerous type of fat so this
is the key here folks exercise is super
important for supporting the type of fat
loss that's not about Aesthetics but
that actually matters for health
keep that in mind now another question
that I'm often asked about fat loss is
related to all of these alleged fat
burning diets and programs super quickly
fasted exercise intermittent fasting
keto and all these like fat burning
supplements have shown no difference in
fat loss in comparison to a control
group facet exercise does burn more fat
but not overall more calories which is
actually what matters when it comes to
losing weight ditto for all these other
diets have suppressed insulin and put
you in fat burning mode like the weight
loss occurs not because of the fat
burning mode but because of the caloric
deficit these things create so just a
quick reminder that phallus doesn't
equal weight loss that's a really
important thing to remember here but
let's say you are on a weight loss
journey and you're actively dieting
whatever that looks like for you I'm not
suggesting anyone needs to do or should
do this is a theoretical scenario but if
this is the path that you've chosen how
can you skew towards fat loss while
maintaining that Health promoting muscle
mass this is really important here folks
so I'm going to give you some
evidence-based tips number one exercise
you guys knew I was gonna say that
I mean you hear all the Bros always
saying that abs are made in the kitchen
and that at least 80 of weight loss is
diet and I'm not debating that diet is
arguably more important when it comes to
weight loss specifically but including
an exercise program along with your diet
will have the greatest impact on one's
ability to maintain or gain muscle while
dieting resistance exercise like
strength training and weight training is
obviously most effective but endurance
exercise is still way better than
nothing Tons Of Studies have
demonstrated that people can maintain
their muscle mass when losing weight if
they are regularly resistance training
now the ideal sweet spot for most people
seems to be around 10 sets of exercises
for each muscle group per week or what
ends up being around three workout days
per week at a high enough intensity that
you are training near muscle failure now
if this feels impossibly intense I know
that I I definitely do not train that
hard remember that this is just the
ideal for like professional style
results all movement is good movement
and will help to support muscle
preservation and this brings me to
another really important piece protein
what I got right here baby
so there is a reason why the vast
majority of popular weight loss diets
promote higher amounts of protein not
only is protein King of the satiety
hierarchy Allah my Hunger crush and
combo but it is imperative to
maintaining muscle while we are losing
weight the faster your weight loss rate
the more protein needed to gain or even
just maintain that protective muscle
mass so assuming that you're sticking to
the recommended weight loss rate of
around one percent weight loss per week
or between one to two pounds of weight
loss per week an intake of 0.8 to 1
grams per pound of body weight will be
enough for most people so for 160 pound
person that's somewhere in the
neighborhood of around 120 to 160 grams
of protein and if that number sounds
really super high it could look
something like this breakfast could be a
cheese and veggie omelette with like two
eggs and two egg whites with some whole
grain toast for snack we could do like a
protein shake lunch could be veggie and
quinoa salad with like three and a half
ounces of chicken breast for snack we
could have a cup of shelled edamame
dinner could be like a veggie rice
stir-fry with like three and a half
ounces of shrimp and bedtime snack could
be a cup of cottage cheese with berries
you guys know I love cottage cheese so
back to the old adage that 80 of fat
loss is diet and 20 is exercise in the
context of maintaining muscle mass to
preserve metabolism while losing weight
we actually see that resistance training
is Queen though a combination of these
two things Reigns Supreme
all right and I like it I love me little
Ryan hold that thought popping these in
a 350 oven for like 20 minutes or
something 20 minutes later so as you can
see from this graph resistance exercise
alone makes up about 87 of the effect of
muscle maintenance and growth in a
calorie deficit while protein makes up
the other 13 so to recap if you're
dieting and actively trying to lose
weight you are naturally at risk of
muscle loss and in order to protect our
metabolism immune function heart health
and strength as we age we want to
minimize that as much as we can you are
at even greater risk of a higher than
average proportion of weight coming from
muscle instead of fat if number one if
you're already at a normal or
underweight BMI category and therefore
have less fat to lose in that
demographic specifically we sometimes
see as much as 35 loss of fat-free Mass
not ideal number two if you're losing
weight faster than recommended rate so
more than one percent per week number
three if you're intermittent fasting
especially if you're doing full day
fasting or the omad diet when you're
only eating one meal a day four if
you're not exercising five if you're not
getting enough protein and six if you
are already over the age of 65. all of
these factors will make dieting and
weight loss a lot more risky for
long-term health so I'm not saying that
you should never attempt weight loss if
you meet any of those criteria but I'm
just warning that if you do it may be
very helpful to seek out professional
support like my go to RDS at unlocked
Fitness Nutrition again I'm going to
leave their contact info below and also
another reminder that this is not a
suggestion to anyone to try to lose
weight or fat it is simply a summary of
the evidence on the safest way to do so
for those who decide to make that choice
for themselves and on that note we got
breakfast for a few days here this is a
built-in hunger crushing combo we got
high fiber carbs in a tortilla plus lots
of protein and healthy fats in our eggs
cheese and nooch I am excited to dig in
and on that note that's all that I have
for you guys today if you like this
video please give it the thumbs up hit
up my description for my new Hunger
crush and combo ebook and I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]